it's an instinctive feeling the horse
brought together
we're not alone
good people will fight if we leave them
people keep telling me they know me
[Music]
no one does
I do
we tuned
and to know
you're coming together
is your undoing
what are we doing there or Threepio
taking one last look sir but my friends
to fear the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
the force will be with you always
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Star Wars Episode nine
trailer breakdown there were so many
Easter eggs and references to Return of
the Jedi
in other films during the saga obviously
it's the last film in the nine film
Skywalker saga there's gonna be lots of
references to the earlier films I'll
just go through shot-by-shot and we'll
break down all the Easter eggs and
foreshadowing if you're brand new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'm doing a Star Wars ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave your
best Palpatine theory on the video
what is Emperor Palpatine going to do
during this movie we start with a shot
of them on the forest planet obviously
giving you a lot of Endor vibes but we
don't know where this is the wreckage of
the second Death Star couldn't have
crashed to this planet too far from
where the forest moon of Endor is but
I'm assuming that this is a different
planet and we're not going straight back
to Endor like all the other planets that
we see in the trailer are confirmed to
be new places we haven't been before but
they all look very similar to earlier
planets we've been to in the saga the
helmet that she throws down looks just
like the helmets that they wore during
the speeder chase during Return of the
Jedi she seems like she's in the middle
of the training exercise because she's
running through the jungle with a
repaired version of Anakin Skywalker's
lightsaber deflecting a blast from what
seems like the same type of small
training droid that Luke used during a
new hope pretty identifiable is a second
Death Star that she's running through
trying to jump from place to place the
large structure behind her also seems
like the same type of console that
obi-wan disabled during a new hope each
of the new mains get voiceover speeches
starting with Finn
talking about feeling that the force
brought them together I have this
feeling obviously they twist it later
with Palpatine's voice over dialogue the
two of you coming together that will be
your downfall we'll talk about Rey in
kylo Ren in a second Poe gets his speech
about how good people will join the
resistance if they lead them well
because they are desperately in need of
reinforcements to fight the first order
so obviously you don't see a ton of
first-order ships it all seems like
classic Star Destroyers I'll talk about
that in a second too but the idea is
that there's been a small time jump
since the end of last Jedi enough time
for Rey to do more force training so she
has a couple of new force abilities but
they've also had time to replenish some
of their forces that's where Lando comes
in because you look here at this giant
shot of the resistance fleet this is
gonna be like the Battle of Endor x 1000
you notice
Falcon swoops into formation in front of
them the ghost from Star Wars rebels is
right here on the right hand side they
also use that during rogue one but it
was kind of in the background we finally
get another new shot of Lando talking to
them while their battle planning you see
Rose Tico come back
this is them standing in front of Poe's
x-wing this is one of the Karelian
Corvettes taking off the forest planet
just like Gabon for during a new hope
obviously referencing other films during
the franchise there are a couple notable
forest planets within the Star Wars
Canon Yavin 4 and Endor just the two big
ones one thing you may have noticed with
the new Star Wars films that they've
done with the capital ships that they
didn't do in the original trilogy is
that they've shown them taking off and
flying around in orbit normally in the
classic trilogy you only see these giant
big ships when they're flying around in
the vacuum of space but one of the
coolest shots in this trailer is of the
Imperial classic Star Destroyer just
rising crashing through this ice
whichever planet this is on then Rey
references the fact that everyone thinks
that she's someone special someone
familiar to them but she still doesn't
have any more information about where
she comes from who she is this is her
preparing for her fight with kylo Ren on
the second Death Star him just walking
through they said they filmed this
forever and it was raining the whole
time just water everywhere he says that
he knows her but I think that he's
speaking metaphorically like he sees
something similar in her not that he's
literally holding her birth certificate
or anything like that his whole thing
during last Jedi was you're nobody you
come from nowhere from scum but I think
you're special this snowy planet is
called Kim G it's controlled entirely by
smugglers and scoundrels
it's where Zuri Bliss's character played
by Keri Russell shows up she's the new
bounty hunter who's meant to be an old
friend of pose and obviously she shows
up here when they're talking to Threepio
press F in the chat for Threepio because
it seems like he's sacrificing himself
but then you see what seems like
Palpatine's sit throne it's kind of hard
to tell where this is or if it's inside
the wreckage of the second Death Star or
somewhere else because it seems like
there's all these rock formations behind
the throne his dialogue is a twist of
Finn's voice over speech like Finn was
saying that it's a good thing that the
force brought them together but
Palpatine is saying that them coming
together will be their downfall but I
think this is the twist is that
Palpatine is only talking about kylo Ren
and Rey the two of you come
together will be your downfall this
might be fin taking this skiff to try
and get to the second Death Star because
then you see him running across one of
the giant bulkheads later as for CP Oh
sacrificing himself remember we saw the
Sith Threepio shot in the last trailer
with his red eyes that might be when
they hack him into this system he might
just be sacrificing himself so they can
gain access to some system if anyone's
gonna make it out of this nine film saga
alive though you'd at least hope that it
would be r2d2 because there has to be
somebody to survive to tell the tale of
what happened and that was kind of r2d2
s role in the classic films he was the
one that carried the message to tell the
story and give people information help
me obi-wan Kenobi you're my only hope
there's another new shot of that tiny
little droid that they introduced next
to bb-8 it's just meant to be a
companion droid that follows bb-8 around
this shot of them charging through the
Imperial ship seems brand new so it's
probably one of the first order Star
Destroyers pretty easy to tell the
difference between the inside of the
second death star in these newer capital
ships you get Luke's voice over saying
confronting fear is the destiny of all
Jedi just like Luke had to make peace
with the fact that Darth Vader was
really his father it kind of implies
that Rey is gonna have to make peace
with some extreme fundamental truth
that's revealed about her origin like if
we're talking about parallels to Return
of the Jedi
what was Luke afraid up during Return of
the Jedi that he would turn to the dark
side enjoying the Emperor
so in Episode nine rise of Skywalker the
emperor is back Rey might also be afraid
of turning to the dark side because we
have a vision of darkside Rey with that
double bladed lightsaber and the last
trailer that we got surprising that they
put all this new Palpatine scenes in the
new trailer but they kept out the sith
version of Rey if you're one of those
people that thinks that Rey is secretly
a clone of Palpatine
there's probably hairs on the back of
your neck standing up watching all this
footage there's a new shot of them
escaping the first order troopers on
this new desert planet they actually
confirmed that the name is Posada so
obviously it's not meant to be tattooing
or jakku or anything like that but it is
meant to be a mirror of the movements of
the original trilogy like you start out
on Tatooine in Episode four in Return of
the Jedi last film of that trilogy you
wind up back on that desert planet
Tatooine then at the beginning of the
new trilogy you start out on jakku
another desert planet makes sense that
you would also go back to a desert
planet in Episode nine the last film in
the Nutri
Lando and Chewie back together again
flying the Falcon just like he did
during Return of the Jedi coming full
circle
since the Falcon was originally his to
begin with not a scratch on her even
though technically I believe Han
bequeathed it to Rey but really I feel
like Chewie should actually be the owner
of the Falcon right now and rages
borrows it from him every once in a
while these just seem like all the
classic imperial star destroyers from
the original trilogy this shot of them
writing those horse like creatures
across the bulkheads of the Star
Destroyers is probably just before they
leave whatever planet they're on and
head up into orbit like it's even more
of them off in the background slowly
taking off this character at the head
leading their charge is Naomi Aki's
brand new character don't know what the
name of her character is then we see by
giving you a bunch of flashbacks kylo
Ren and Rey inside the wreckage of the
Emperor's throne room on the second
Death Star so this is progression of
kylo Ren rape footage where first you
see them fighting outside but then you
see them working together inside the
second Death Star so it's like we're
slowly traveling to the innermost cave
if you're talking about Joseph
Campbell's hero's journey and you
eventually see the two of them with
probably the most interesting shot in
the trailer inside this weird white room
there's a scene of kylo Ren and Rayce
smashing this black structure this might
be something connected to the Emperor
inside the second Death Star some
communication device where he's speaking
to them it's too blurry to make it out
really specifically but my first
instinct actually when I saw this was
that they were smashing Darth Vader's
helmet so it could be connected to that
too because the design language of this
white room is different from anything
that we've seen in Star Wars before but
it feels very 70s old-school like it's
very similar to what you would have seen
inside the second Death Star like a
special secret room that the Emperor had
that we never saw inside that Death Star
really hard to tell where this planet is
but it's just another wide shot of their
charge as they rush across the
old-school Star Destroyers with a bunch
of them in the background taking off
into orbit this area where Rey is
looking up at someone approaching her
from above seems like it's the same rock
formations is where Palpatine sit throne
was so she might actually be looking at
him here floating in the air coming to
her and the final shot of her here with
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber raised up
in the battle ready position just seems
like it's heard slowly getting her [ __ ]
together before some big big boss fight
like I said it seems like it's a pretty
clear narrative what Palpatine is trying
to do I've been waiting a long time for
this like he's been hiding biding his
time building forces getting ready to
jump back in after the galaxy has become
destabilized enough and weak enough to
provide him an opportunity to come back
and take over again what's not clear
though is if he has his physical body
and he's back or if it's his force
spirit because technically there are
some pretty big rules about who can
become a force ghost and who can't
and even though SIF can become force
spirits usually those spirits are bound
to objects like holocrons or objects or
places so the emperor spirit might just
be trapped inside the second Death Star
this whole time I've already talked
about theories about how he's trying to
inhabit someone's body to come back but
I would not be surprised if they go for
the dark empire twist with their special
cloning tanks where he's been trying to
inhabit new people's bodies to really
come back the whole idea though rise of
Skywalker I think implies redemption of
Ben solo so somehow he will redeem
himself and defeat Palpatine if we're
talking about parallels to return the
Jedi pull a Darth Vader and throw him
down another shaft but this time the
death will stick because it clearly did
not stick when Darth Vader tried to kill
him but if you spotted any other big
easter eggs in the trailer that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments what I'll do is is
I'll do new Star Wars video in the next
couple of weeks because we have the
Mandalorian coming up I'll be doing
episode videos for that I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post that next
video as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see the videos
when I post them everybody click here
for my Mandalorian trailer video and
Easter eggs
and click here for that new Avengers
infinity saga trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight